reading hang on
I know these motherfuckers are Weaver's
because of that stupid fucking loom of
fate but how did a class of Bloomie's
just suddenly become expert assassins
it's not like they had any formal
training right they weren't hunters or
warriors even gatherers this group of
assholes continued to call themselves
the fraternity even though they became
partially comprised of women look at the
evil boss lady is overweight and older
but otherwise this is an impossible
amount of good-looking women on this
staff it's a king accounting firm not a
Hollywood agency for God's sake standard
whores I'm finding it hard to care about
anything these days ennui raishin the
only thing I do care about is the fact
that I can't care about anything
even though Wesley is a desk jockey that
works with spreadsheets all day he has
an active camera feed of his face on his
desktop Leslie Gipson types his own name
into Google a fairly common name and
gets no results I'm surprised goggle
didn't sue over this it takes 10 seconds
and 9 guts to show this asshole walking
down a hallway we'd like to know where
our competitor is getting his diminished
leader we find out that the guys across
the street are assassins but how did
they know that this dude would be here
trying to get information about a bullet
at this exact time this woman checking
the bullet obviously didn't expect him
to be here today so how did the
assassins figure it out okay meaning
it's untraceable this is said after
three whole seconds of looking at the
bullet with a magnification of two four
amazing marksmen with few rifles missed
the Irish guy from Braveheart after
being able to center an aiming dot on an
Indian woman's bindi this highly trained
assassin resorts to the same futile
method of speeding up elevator doors as
teenagers and a horror movie
I guess this lady making copies didn't
hear all the glass breaking and the guy
running into three people in the hallway
this presentation has to be ready by
5:00 p.m. god damn it and Carol isn't
stealing her thunder mr. X smashes
through the window starts killing dudes
which is cool I guess I'm just wondering
why these assassins are still here since
he was obviously headed for the elevator
and was out of range a second ago also
while it's amazing he can do this type
of thing why the can't they shoot him
they were just the decoys by mr. ace
I know these fraternity bastards are
hard to kill but this is the super
elaborate ruse to take mr. X out
considering Wesley's dad could have done
it while he was flying through the
fucking air trying to kill those minions
I know what's Lee's girlfriend is it
cheating no-good hussy but this sounds
like the first time she's ever
complained about something that likely
happens every single day
I can't tell if using Nine Inch Nails
every day's exactly the same is
brilliantly appropriate or so incredibly
obvious has to be simple hmm gotta think
about that one seemed very you had to go
to the dentist again sudden adulterated
Chris Pratt
so geez these guys had the exact same
sex every day basically clothes and in
the same position cheating on your
boyfriend looks super boring movie
doesn't trust us to realize how awful
this boss is so it goes way over the top
to prove the point
you know if Wesley staying later than
anyone else in this office why the hell
isn't he getting those billing reports
done the evil boss lady has a point it's
been less time bitching about his life
and googling himself maybe he'd be a
little more productive wait this is the
same day as the last time Wesley went to
the pharmacy which is simple even though
he's having a rough time no pink
pharmacist it's gonna give you a refill
of your relaxing pills in the same
goddamn day you apologize too much I
know everyone's supposed to be looking
cool and all but Fox is on the hunt for
the most dangerous assassin that's ever
assassin and yet she still engages in
some misleading sexy small talk before
the movie begins to actually get wanted
your father died yesterday on the
rooftop of the metropolitan building and
I just felt like the pharmacy was the
best place to tell you all this it was
the greatest assassins who ever lived
seriously she's discussing this here why
and then who killed him is behind you
this is Angelina Jolie's killing face
until this movie the only people that
had seen it were Billy Bob Thornton who
barely escaped and a random hooker in
Death Valley who unfortunately didn't
Fox does this because just firing her
super powerful gun through the
impenetrable forces of potato chip bags
would make killing this dude impossible
is it just me or is this bullet that is
going through all the cereal pretty slow
I mean we can see each individual box
getting blown off the shelf it's pretty
avoidable the schools this shot is
Wesley's knees and ankles survived this
please please strike fast poopy inflicts
damage by causing memories have gone in
60 seconds goddammit when will movie
stop trying to convince me that large
slow clunky trucks can totally keep pace
with sleek speedy turn on a dime sports
cars
apparently this movie thought it needed
James McAvoy to be the most annoying
sidekick in a movie since Kate Capshaw
and the Temple of Doom what's worse is
he's supposed to be the hero by the end
of it which means the movie felt the
need to really hammer home how pathetic
he is because the first 17 minutes
didn't do that already Fox doesn't think
this is the most efficient way to kill
the assassin but how else is she gonna
show Wesley her vagina during this fight
damn it it's amazing that it took this
long for one of these super
highly-trained assholes to remember to
aim at the entire movie unintentionally
inspire as much of the bullshit that's
now featured in The Fast and Furious
franchise Vin Diesel bends one bullet in
the next movie so help me God say the
right rear tire was shot out right now
that because this car doing anything
cool right now I mean okay I guess we're
forgetting all about that instead of
immediately going after the car that
started this whole thing and just
recently flipped over them the cops
investigate a truck that lightly tapped
one of their vehicles shoot the wings
off the flies this is an exercise to
show Wesley his skills but mostly it's
an indictment on this secret assassin
headquarters terrible health code
standards insanity is being dawn
beatdown coasting through life and a
miserable existence when you have a key
to lie unlocked inside and the key to
release it
Sloan pitched the same line to the
company that makes those inspirational
office posters but was sadly denied this
gun you're holding belonged to your
father
dad's position
I'm not sure if I've mentioned how
matrix this movie is trying to be it is
so mate ryx Keanu Reeves accidentally
thought he was in this movie when it
came out also is there any reason why
they took him back to his place I mean
they want him to be on the team and they
appear not to be giving him much choice
so I don't understand why they took him
back here Plus did he get here on his
own power because that must have been
some seen when the fraternity dragged
his unconscious body up to his apartment
and put him in bed next to his
unobservant girlfriend this article
tells us eight bodies were found on top
of the roof of this building but only
five people died on top of the building
and one died in the other building from
across the way so who else can died
during that scene I mean the answer is
whoever with this article dug right
junior high
must've been kind of tough but it
doesn't give you the right to treat your
workers like horse Janus what I'd rather
be watching is a Janus origin story in
order to explain how such an obnoxious
person with little to do except give
people she was put in charge of a very
large accounting firm in downtown
Chicago okay
we're gonna need you to omit Chris Pratt
no emote the entire office Barry somehow
heard this whispered insult from all the
way across the entire office roll credit
also these are the worst facial
composites ever drawn these assholes
have tons of surveillance video footage
to examine then they came up with these
at least 80% of Angelina Jolie's
performance in this movie is comprised
of sexy staring this goes on for some
time oh that's silly internet craze back
in 2008 known as Han Solo in the
memories vodka yeah Russian yeah because
only Russians would ever give vodka to
someone kinda racist but I'll roll with
it this is the gunsmith who knows more
about a piece than anybody and he's
gonna teach you how to use yeah some
would say he has uncommon knowledge
about guns if no one told you that
bullets flew straight and I gave you a
gun and told you to hit the target what
would you do
ignore physics and logic I guess
seriously the since does this question
make once again movie suggests that no
one is currently looking out there el
adjacent window in downtown Chicago or
if they are they just don't give a shit
about these two assholes on top of a
train you gotta rip this perfect shot
and pass
boy I would love for this movie to
define what actually is and isn't
possible in this universe in there Jesus
Christ this dude is more obnoxious than
Luke Skywalker on diggable he's seen all
this crazy and he knows he's being
trained to do superhero like tasks but
at every new challenge he's got a bitch
about how impossible it is ready when
Fox says you're ready isn't that you why
are you talking about yourself in the
third person
oh wait that's a different movie that
came out this year damn I'm getting my
foxes all mixed up
people think you use cheese to catch
these beauties lets-a-go eggs for being
on the back road and shadow Sony in
front of a moving train no this guy is
whistling the universal signal for
Angelina Jolie is naked somewhere and
all males in the vicinity need to take
notice also I don't know what she did
today where she needed to get into the
healing Han Solo Carbonite but this
movie's marketing is glad she did in
character finally says the right thing
under extreme duress cliche Hill cross
had to become his student memorize every
move he ever made or just shoot your gun
with the proper bendy method when you
faced off against him that'll work too
he was always one chest move ahead
this sequence mixes in Wesley's
improvement and knife skills shuttle
catching and homework so I guess we
could call this a montage onto all it's
kind of amazing but this is a task
Leslie needs to master for his training
I mean we're in a world where these guys
can curve bullets what would this skill
be useful for movie makes it seem like
Wesley is making a bold creative choice
when in fact he's going to be hit by all
the traffic most of the times he might
try this yeah he curved the bullet I
would have removed 50 sins at the bullet
curve but still missed the target and
another hundred if it killed Fox this
movies trying to make it sound like if
they successfully curved the bullet it
always hits its target which i think is
ludicrous also considering that the
fraternity has these healing pools I'm
not sure what the total danger is here I
guess he could hit her in the brain or
their heart or something and it would be
something beyond a healing back but you
know call me crazy I just don't think
the character played by Angelina Jolie
has a chance in hell of getting harmed
in this scene
for tigers name also apparently only
enough to do something wants to pass the
test in the spring club I mean he did
the bullet thing under the heavy stress
of not killing fox so who's to say he
could do that true began without any
prompting a thousand years ago a clan of
Weaver's discovered a mystical language
hidden in the fabric this ping loom of
Destiny and its bull the plot driven
bullet movie was fine when it was just
about assassins doing assassin stuff but
then it's itself right its own fucking
asshole with his flume and its ping bull
look I thought you'd brought me here to
kill cross will in time Sloane had his
cross killing boner raging several days
ago when Wesley wasn't getting the
training Wesley's the only one who can
get to him
cross gets closer with each hour but now
he's fine taking some practice strokes
the target will be in the conference
room sitting at the head chair does this
guy always sit in the conference room at
a certain time of day every day why
can't they kill this dude when he's at
home I don't know if he was bad
Wesley's hanging out in the recovery
bath even though he wasn't injured
during the mission in the hopes he can
get another wide-angle shot of
Angelina's nude body double Rudy had an
enormous candle budget but was
apparently only allowed to candle in one
shop we don't know how far the ripples
of our decisions go kill one and maybe
save a thousand that's all well and good
but it still seems arbitrary like how
many people are you not killing because
the Loom doesn't tell you about but
they're responsible for some horrible
crime let's not forget the seams all
relegated to the city of Chicago which
is apparently the sphere of influence
for the entire world
this asshole had a clean straight on
shot when he failed to pull the trigger
the last time but besides this time he
needs to curve the bullet for some bulk
reason target will be in a black limo he
always travels the same six blocks
hostage you don't need to know the time
he does this just go to Halsted whenever
you want he's probably there being a
dick in his limo so many things here
first off his tires don't even move to
the right so it's basically flipping to
the right on its own without him
steering it that way
second you have all the information in
the world about a target and you got
decided that the best time to kill him
is when he's in his bulletproof limo
fact you did not discover for some
reason until you were on the job third
why is this ramping even necessary can't
you just find a way to curve a bullet
into his sunroof or is the curving just
a horizontal thing fourth this is why
grenades or a thing I don't know feel
like adding five cents for this scene
also why did they even show cops
pursuing them earlier in the movie it
definitely disappeared since then
considering it's not like these
assassins have been discreet or anything
just curb the bullet man curving makes
for an accurate shot every time assassin
walks up behind another assassin without
a word and expects that assassin not to
assassin this house somehow this
literally translates to when you have a
chance somehow catch a thousand mice
using peanut butter strap bombs on them
find a way to infiltrate the
headquarters and blow them up and Wesley
gets the message why did they leave this
canister with a mouse inside it just
lying on the floor is it so the movie
could remind us and James McAvoy about
the mouse bomb from earlier which will
now figure into the finale I go alone or
he doesn't show okay the fact that Kraus
has a loom panel is an obvious tip-off
that he's not the real villain here
considering the luma boy spits that
stuff out only by fate does Wesley think
cross his name just coincidentally came
up around the same time he went rogue so
this is the birthplace of the fraternity
which has its own loom of fate and
everything but is Terence Stamp the only
person who works here anymore that must
be a tough job keeping up with all those
assassination jobs all on your own at
the age of 70 oh look I guess there are
no cops in this made-up Eastern European
city either this dude who looks nothing
like cross gets mistaken for him
nonetheless Fox drives down one of those
movie roads where you can chase after a
train and no one is ever in your way I
tried this there would be some asshole
and a tractor driving down this road
geez this is the third time their
bullets have hit each other in midair
this feels like the precursor to Harry
Potter and Voldemort
well those innocent assholes are now
dead which means Fox essentially killed
them with that stupid car stunt man
should therefore have her assassin car
every vote Wesley survives this oh and
this two older character has dying words
for the protagonist cliche Jesus is he
gonna reference a prophecy about Wesley
being the one of us god dammit
also why couldn't this do tell him that
earlier he obviously can figure out when
Wesley goes to the grocery store hangs
out in the back alley next to a train
station but he couldn't figure out where
he lived and at least slipped on a note
not only did Fox and possibly survive
the fall on the train car she's healthy
enough to sexily skulk in the background
until prompted by the script this train
is derailed on a bridge over the deepest
chasm on the planet allowing Wesley to
have a few more seconds with his dad
Wesley's dad found an apartment nearby
where he could watch his son sometimes
have sex with his girlfriend but
sometimes watch Wesley's best friend
have sex with his girlfriend I promised
your father I'd bring you back wait so
the limey was able to catch up to the
train locate the exact spot where Wesley
and cross fell into the water save
Wesley make the trek back up the
mountain keep him alive on the entire
trip back to Chicago then put him in the
recovery tank and do all this without
any helper without anyone
ever since fox had her teeth in you he's
been trying to separate you from them
but instead of sending some emails notes
or phone calls he preferred the let's
keep pretending I'm a bad guy he was
trying to shoot you method of getting
the message across your father got hold
of this decipher it yourself Kraus had
the looms watch that name Sloan for some
reason but didn't write down who it was
so we could have an extremely obvious
whammy to set up the final lap yes okay
so why weren't any of the other
fraternities notified about Sloan
why weren't they given a kill order when
clearly one of their own had gone rope
or does this go a long way backing up
the idea that Chicago is the only town
where a magic loom tells assassins whom
to kill you want me to run god damn it
this asshole dragged this other asshole
all the way back to Chicago which is the
home of Sloan's army too telling me
needs to flee somewhere else and why the
when you need to see crosses house to
believe he was his father
goodness dude just show him the pictures
back in Europe goddamn it this movie
gets real stupid at the end wesley is
buying a ton of peanut butter but
wouldn't the fraternity of MPD's bank
account if they have the power to give
him three million dollars overnight they
certainly have the power to take it away
right
haha it's like a mini Batman Returns
only the Penguins are rats now also but
the trucks where the peanut butter is
why would the rants leave the peanut
buttery truck for a non peanut buttery
environment doesn't make sense
damn he surrounds infiltrated deep into
the fraternities inner sanctum in like
ten seconds here's your usual action
scene piled with edits galore but my
real question is how are there's still
this many henchmen alive after a
thousand of those bombs went off guy who
is good at knives mrs. Wesley here and
then becomes a horror movie dick for the
rest of the scene until he dies also did
he just stay in his butcher shop all the
bombs went off or just like a video game
where you fight the boss on his home
turf
[Applause]
slow instead of helping out the butcher
or anyone else during Wesley's homicidal
rampage all the important assassins hid
like bitches up in the library why is
nobody killing Wesley right now sure
he's about to give them proof that
Sloane is a bad guy but they don't know
that yet
they've all got standing orders to kill
Wesley right now Hey wanted you dead my
question is why is the loom tell the
head of the fraternity that it wanted
Sloane dead the Loom was terribly stupid
to trust Sloane with this information
your name came up and because we haven't
given your character any definition I
wrote your nickname on the kill order
your name came up your name came up your
name so did the loom want all these
people dead or did you just want to end
the fraternity or did it want them dead
because of the things they were going to
do because Sloane told them to do it the
loom is mysterious and idiotic shoot
this motherfucker and let us take our
fraternity of assassins to heights
reserved only for the gods of men damn
it Morgan Freeman you are a national
treasure this magic bullet which was
definitely used to kill JFK manages to
go through several skulls in a circle
without once slowing down and I guess
it's lucky everyone was in a perfect
circle for this to happen this is just a
motherfuckin decoy yeah but how did you
know that Sloane would show up here why
would he expect you to go back to your
former place of work
can you fill in one gap please what have
you done lately is this movie haunting
me because I haven't killed people like
Wesley has the message of this movie is
either be bored at your job and let your
best friend your girlfriend or be an
assassin how many sins is that mmm
doesn't seem like enough of this movie
hey remember that woman about Nine Inch
Nails that I couldn't decide about
earlier yeah I made up my mind
[Music]
but let them I didn't receive a piece
and I was told just pass hello
[Music]
and the others you see around you are
all very good at killing so if I were
you I'd keep the gun pointed at me come
on what you got in me what you got in me
there you go
just great bro who's the me bang bang
bang shoot shoot shoot bullet bullet gun
that that that
[Music]